Este vídeo ha sido patrocinado por Surfshark
VPN. Luego os doy más detalles pero antes,
vamos con nuestra historia de hoy.
INTRO VISUALPOLITIK
Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Cuál es el
arma más cara de la historia? Pues no,
no es ni una bomba atómica, ni tampoco la
cúpula antimisiles de Israel: el arma más cara
de la historia es el caza de combate F-35.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos,
sobre todo los que estéis familiarizados con
este tema: ¡Fonseca, no es verdad! Hay aviones
de combate mucho más caros que el F-25. Por
ejemplo, un F-22 puede costar unos 300 millones
de dólares por unidad mientras que el F-35 puede
costar menos de 80 millones de euros. Pero lo que
hace que este avión sea tan increíblemente caro es
el coste para desarrollarlo. Agarraos a la silla
porque la cifra os va a dejar temblando: 400.000
millones de dólares. Para que os hagáis una idea,
eso es más que todo el PIB de un país tan grande
como Egipto. La Estación Espacial Internacional,
que tampoco salió barata costó “sólo” 150.000
millones de dólares ¡Pero esperad un momento
porque esto no es todo! Cuando hablamos de gasto
militar, normalmente nos olvidamos de una parte
importante: el mantenimiento. Es decir, el coste
de tener todos los F 35 listos para el combate:
reparaciones, combustible, actualizaciones... Pues
bien, si contamos todo esto, podemos decir que el
coste total del F 35 supera los 1,1 Billones de
dólares (y sí, Billones en castellano, en inglés
sería trillions) en las próximas décadas. Si os
habéis perdido con las cifras, pensadlo así por un
momento: es más de la mitad de todo el presupuesto
de la Unión Europea. Presupuesto que hemos
criticado varias veces aquí, en VisualPolitik,
porque nos parece una auténtica orgía de gasto
público. En este caso, hablamos de una auténtica
salvajada sólo para desarrollar este avión que
veis en pantalla. Y, por supuesto, aunque lo
haya desarrollado una empresa privada, no os
equivoquéis: todo ese dinero viene del bolsillo
de los contribuyentes, tanto los de Estados
Unidos como los de Reino Unido, Países Bajos y
otros tantos países. Luego os explicaré por qué.
Y lo que ahora os estaréis preguntando todos es...
¿De verdad merece la pena gastarse tanto dinero?
¿De verdad es tan increíble este F 35? Pues esta
es la misma pregunta que se llevan haciendo en
Washington durante años. Desde John McCain hasta
Donald Trump, muchos políticos estadounidenses
han criticado duramente el programa del F 35. Y
la polémica continúa. Veréis, seguro que todos
os habréis preguntando muchas veces si de verdad
es tan importante el gasto militar: especialmente
los que veáis este vídeo desde Estados Unidos.
Por supuesto que nadie cuestiona que todos los
países necesitan ejército pero… ¿Hacia dónde va
tantísimo gasto público? ¿Por qué el proyecto del
F-35 ha costado tanto dinero? ¿Cómo funciona
el mercado del armamento? Atentos porque a
través del ejemplo del F-35, vamos a aprender
muchas cosas sobre el mundo del armamento. Porque
hoy, vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas
pero antes… antes vamos a hablar de defensa y
seguridad pero no para un país entero sino para
TU ordenador o TU teléfono móvil ¿Cómo podemos
evitar la mayoría de los hackers por Internet?
¿Cómo podemos proteger nuestra privacidad en
la red? ¡Exacto! Usando una VPN ¿Y cuál es
la VPN favorita de VisualPolitik? ¡Lo sabéis
todos los que seguís este canal! Surfshark VPN.
Surfshark VPN no sólo nos permite ver webs de
cualquier país… además nos permite hacerlo sin
miedo a llenar nuestro ordenador o nuestro móvil
de virus. Y, creedme, el tema de la ciberseguridad
se lo toman en serio. Por ejemplo, Surfshark
tiene una herramienta que se llama CLEANWEB
que bloquea todos los popups de propaganda,
por donde se cuelan más bots y cookies que no
queremos tener. Por si todo esto fuera poco,
con una misma cuenta de Surfshark podrás
registrar todos los dispositivos que quieras
¿Quieres navegar con seguridad desde tu SmartTV?
¿Desde tu móvil? ¿Desde tu ordenador? Puedes hacer
todo esto con la misma cuenta de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos una oferta especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik. Si
utilizáis el código POLITIK podréis disfrutar de
un 83% de descuento más 3 meses extra totalmente
gratuitos. Tenéis el link en la descripción. No
esperéis más y descargaros ya la aplicación.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
UN CAZA PARA UNIRLOS A TODOS
Puede que os sorprenda pero la idea inicial
del F-35 era… ¡Ahorrar gastos! Tal cual como lo
oís. Nuestra historia empieza en los años 90. La
Guerra Fría había terminado. Eso significa que ya
no había un gigante como la Unión Soviética
con el que competir en armamento. Así que,
tanto el ejército americano como muchos otros
ejércitos aliados decidieron optimizar costes,
al menos en los cazas de combate ¿Cómo? Pues
primero, uniendo fuerzas para desarrollar un
único caza para todos los países. Es
decir, Estados Unidos, Reino Unido,
Canadá o Países Bajos y otros aliados se
unieron para crear el JOINT STRIKE FIGHTER
PROGRAM. Podríamos decir que este programa
era algo así como una carta a Santa Claus
con todas las condiciones que tenía que tener
este nuevo caza de combate. De esta forma,
podían hacer un pedido mucho más grande a la
empresa proveedora. Al hacer un pedido más grande,
se genera una economía de escala y se pueden
abaratar costes. Tiene sentido ¿Verdad?
¿Y que pusieron en esa carta a los Reyes Magos?
Pues, para optimizar aún más los costes, hicieron
algo parecido a lo que años más tarde harían
las empresas de vuelos low-cost como Ryanair:
usando un único modelo de avión que sirva para
todo. Porque sí, cada caza de combate está
pensado para un uso muy concreto. Por ejemplo,
los HARRIER son unos aviones fantásticos para dar
apoyo a tropas de tierra ¿Por qué? Pues entre
otras muchas cosas, porque pueden aterrizar y
despegar de forma vertical, como si fueran un
helicóptero. Esto permite operar en casi todo
tipo de zonas. Sin embargo, un Harrier no sirve
para atacar otros aviones de combate porque no
puede alcanzar velocidad supersónica. Así que,
si quieres estar listo para combates aire-aire,
necesitas también una flota de F-16. Esto
significa que necesitas tener ingenieros de
mantenimiento y recambio de cada uno de los
modelos de caza ¿Conclusión? Una auténtica
fortuna.
Así que
el plan maestro del ejército era
un caza para unirlos a todos:
un avión todoterreno que pudiera
1. romper la barrera del sonido,
2, aterrizar y despegar verticalmente y 3 y
más importante, que fuera furtivo. Es decir,
que ningún radar lo pudiera detectar. Ya en
los años 90 había aviones que tuvieran alguna
de estas características. Pero juntar las 3
en un único caza era un prodigio nunca visto.
Pues bien, con esta carta a Santa Claus se
convocó un concurso al que se presentaron las
empresas armamentísticas más importantes
del mundo. Finalmente, en el año 2001,
el jurado nombró al ganador. Atentos.
El equipo de Lockheed Martin gana la
competición del Joint Strike Fighter
Quedaos con el nombre de esta empresa.
Desde que ganaron el concurso, el precio
de sus acciones se ha multiplicado por 6.
Pensadlo bien: Lockheed Martin ha desarrollado
un avión pensado para sustituir a casi todas
las flotas de cazas de Estados Unidos
y Aliados. Para que os hagáis una idea,
sólo el Pentágono ha hecho un pedido de más de
2400 cazas. Ganar este contrato fue un auténtico
boom para la empresa. Pero también fue en este
momento cuando empezó la pesadilla del F-35.
EL ARMA MÁS CARA DE LA HISTORIA
El F-35 ya estaba a punto de hacerse realidad.
Lockheed Martin había diseñado un avión que lo
tenía todo: era furtivo, supersónico, podía
despegar y aterrizar verticalmente y además
tenía el último grito en software. Y para eso,
tanto Estados Unidos como el resto de países
del programa les pusieron 298.000 millones de
dólares en la mesa. Puede parecer mucho dinero
pero recordad que hablamos de renovar
casi toda la flota de cazas de combate.
¿El problema? El problema vino a la hora de
fabricarlo en masa. De entrada, no había un
único modelo de F-35. En realidad había 3: el F-35
A para combate aéreo, el F-35 B para aterrizaje y
despegue vertical y el F-35 C, que tendría alas
plegables y que estaba pensado para operaciones
de rescate. En principio, ambos aviones iban a
ser muy parecidos. Pero, a medida que avanzaba la
producción, empezaron a surgir pequeños problemas,
principalmente con el software ¿Conclusión? Los
distintos modelos de F-35 no son tan parecidos
entre sí y, en muchos casos, necesitan personal
especializado para el mantenimiento.
¡Pero ojalá este fuera el único problema!
La idea de Lockheed Martin era lo que se llama
“DESARROLLO CONCURRENTE” ¿Y esto qué significa?
Pues que en lugar de esperar a tener todos
los diseños listos para producirlos en masa,
la empresa empieza a fabricar aviones en
versión “beta”. Luego, a medida que avanzan
los del departamento del I+D, se hacen mejoras
a los aviones que ya se han desarrollado. La
idea de esta estrategia era producir más
rápido. Pero produjo el resultado contrario.
Cada vez que se iban a introducir mejoras en esos
aviones versión beta, aparecían nuevos problemas.
Y todos estos problemas se traducían en dos cosas:
retrasos y dinero, muchísimo dinero. Atentos.
El coste del programa del F-35 sube a 406.600
millones de dólares en la última estimación
Habéis oído bien: lo que en principio no llegaba
a 300.000 millones de dólares (¡Que ya es dinero!)
ha terminado superando los 400.000. Y aquí
hay interpretaciones para todos los gustos.
Hay quien dice que todo esto son problemas
comprensibles. Pero no son pocos quienes se
quejan de la falta de incentivos de la empresa
para optimizar gastos. A fin de cuentas ¿Por
qué iban a hacerlo? Una vez se les ha adjudicado
el contrato y se ha empezado a gastar el dinero,
nadie va a cortar el proyecto en seco. Sería
tirar a la basura toda la inversión. Así que
tanto Estados Unidos como el resto de
aliados se han visto obligados a seguir
pagando todos los sobrecostos para, al
menos, poder tener ese ansiado F-35.
¡Pero aquí no termina la cosa! El F-35 no
sólo es caro en su desarrollo. También en el
mantenimiento y en el uso. Por ejemplo, volar
un caza F-15 EX cuesta unos 28.000 dólares
por hora. Un F-35 cuesta más de 45.000
dólares por hora. Dicho de otra forma:
que sí, será un caza increíble pero… hay que
pensarse dos veces antes de ponerlo a volar.
Y ahora hay dos preguntas que os estaréis
haciendo. La primera ¿Existen ya F-35s en uso?
Pues sí, después de una infinidad de retrasos,
en 2015 salieron los primeros F-35 listos para el
combate. Sin embargo, todavía hoy, más de 20 años
después de que Lockheed Martin ganara el contrato,
quedan miles de aviones por terminar.
La segunda pregunta es… ¿De verdad ha
merecido la pena tantísimo dinero?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UN SUPERCOMPUTADOR CON ALAS
Esto que veis en pantalla es una de las
partes más importantes del F-35: el casco.
Para que os hagáis una idea, cada uno de estos
cascos vale más de 400.000 dólares. Y diréis
¿Pero qué tiene de especial? Pues, entre
otras cosas, permite que el piloto vuele
el avión como si fuera en una alfombra mágica.
Es decir, que puede ver el exterior del avión…
sin el fuselaje. Todo esto es gracias a los
muchísimos radares que lleva el F-35. No es un
caza cualquiera: es un supercomputador con alas.
Y, por lo que dicen los que lo han pilotado,
es una auténtica maravilla. De hecho, en muchos
casos se pueden dar órdenes por voz. Es decir,
es como si tuviera el “Siri” o el “OK Google”
de los teléfonos móviles… pero versión militar
¡Pero no sólo eso! Los F-35 recolectan toda la
información y la comparten, tanto con el apoyo
en tierra como con otros aviones. Y esto
es una auténtica revolución en los cazas.
No hace falta que os diga que pilotar
un caza de combate es complicadísimo.
Por un lado, los mandos de cabina están llenos
de botones a los que hay que prestar atención.
Pero recordad que no sólo estamos volando:
estamos en combate. Hay que estar pendiente
de volar y, a la vez, de detectar al enemigo,
dispararle y evitar que te dispare. Vamos,
una auténtica locura. Pues bien, el F-35
procesa toda la información de los radares
y envía órdenes claras y directas al piloto.
Es más, incluso puede compartir información
con tanques o baterías de misiles, o incluso
otros F-35s. Es más, incluso puede compartir
información con tanques, baterías de misiles, o
incluso otros F-35s. Esto permite triangulizar
de forma automática dónde está
un radar enemigo, por ejemplo.
¿Entendéis ahora por qué el software del
F-35 daba tantos problemas? Es una parte
fundamental de este caza de combate.
Podemos decir que el F-35 no es sólo
un avión. Es todo un sistema para compartir
información de forma automática en el campo
de combate. Es Big Data aplicado a la guerra.
Y por supuesto, a todo esto hay que sumarle el
hecho de ser un avión furtivo. Todos los
modelos de F-35 son capaces de volar sin
ser detectados por ningún radar ni ninguna
cámara de calor. Y esto es todo un prodigio
técnico. Pensad que un motor de un avión
supersónico tiende a calentarse. Evitar
que lo detecte una cámara de calor requiere
un auténtico prodigio de la ingeniería.
Dicho de otra forma: ¿Es el F-35 un buen avión?
La respuesta es sí. De hecho, se dice que tendrá
una vigencia de más de 40 años. Es decir, que para
el año 2060 seguiremos oyendo hablar de los F-35s.
Y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo todos ahora
es ¿Qué impacto va a tener el F-35 en la guerra
moderna? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UNA SEÑAL PARA CHINA
Con la información que tenemos en este momento,
se puede decir que el F-35 no tiene rival en el
mundo. Lo más parecido a este caza de combate
sería el J-20 chino. Pero, por lo que dicen los
expertos, no es ni de lejos tan impresionante
como el F-35 ¡Ojo! Existen cazas más rápidos o
con mejor capacidad de maniobra. Por ejemplo, el
F-22 es muy superior en muchas cosas. Ahora bien,
el F-22 es un caza que sólo está disponible
para Estados Unidos y que cuesta más de 300
millones de dólares por unidad. Dicho de otra
forma, el F-35 está destinado a ser el caza de
referencia de casi todos los aliados del Tío Sam.
De hecho, ni siquiera Estados Unidos fue el primer
país en usarlo en combate. Los primeros
en estrenar el F-35 fueron los israelíes.
Pero, por encima de todo, lo más importante
de este nuevo y flamante caza de combate…
es que es toda una señal para China. Atentos.
Singapur está en la etapa final para adquirir
cuatro cazas F-35, que serán
entregados a finales de 2026
Estados Unidos da luz verde a Japón para comprar
el F-35s por valor de 23.000 millones de dólares
Japón, Singapur, Corea del Sur… todos estos son
países de Asia que están renovando sus flotas
de aviación con armamento de Estados Unidos.
Armamento con el que, al menos que se sepa,
China no puede competir. Todo esto cumple un
objetivo: los países que rodean a China se
están armando para evitar una posible expansión
del gigante asiático. Y lo hacen reforzando sus
lazos militares con Estados Unidos. Dicho de
otra forma, el F-35 está ayudando a que el
Tío Sam mantenga sus aliados en Asia. Lo mismo
ocurre en Europa, donde casi todos los países
de la OTAN han comprado o se están planteando
comprar F-35s para renovar sus flotas de cazas.
Por supuesto que todavía quedan unos pocos
años para que Lockheed Martin entregue todos
los pedidos que le han hecho. Y todavía hoy
nos encontramos con problemas de retrasos.
Pero podemos decir que los F-35 se están
convirtiendo en el objeto de deseo de
casi todos los ejércitos del mundo. Al
menos, los aliados de Estados Unidos.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿Creéis
que Estados Unidos va a hacer un buen negocio
vendiendo el F-35 a sus aliados… aunque sea en
el largo plazo? ¿Habría sido posible desarrollar
este caza de combate por menos dinero? ¿Es
posible controlar los gastos de la industria
militar? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas. Así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si
os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.